My name is Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。令我惊讶的是，通往这一职业的道路竟有如此之多，而且并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我感到自信，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的自我压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. What happens when you land the job you thought you wanted and then realize it's all wrong? If you've ever started a new role and felt completely out of place, anxious,
所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来了。当你得到了你以为自己想要的工作，却发现完全不对劲时，会发生什么？如果你曾经开始一份新工作，却感到格格不入、焦虑、
undermined, questioning everything, you're not alone. In this episode, we're talking about the mental toll of hating your new job, the hidden role of workplace culture, and what it takes to walk away with your confidence and your sanity intact. Hope you find it so useful. I welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
感到被削弱、质疑一切，你并不孤单。在这一集中，我们将讨论讨厌新工作带来的心理负担、职场文化的隐性作用，以及如何带着自信和理智全身而退。希望你觉得这很有用。欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
You are so welcome. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, workplaces can be big and scary places to be and it's understandable that we might feel a little bit out of sorts when we start a new job but we would quickly expect that to adjust and for us to feel hopefully like we were in the right place but that's not always the case and today I'm talking to a leadership consultant Kelly about a very recent experience
非常欢迎。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。职场可能是一个庞大而可怕的地方，当我们开始一份新工作时，感到有些不适应是可以理解的，但我们通常希望这种感觉能很快调整过来，希望自己能感到身处正确的地方，但事实并非总是如此。今天，我将与领导力顾问凯利谈谈她最近的一次经历，
she's had that really has helped her to embody everything that she practices and she preaches. It is a beautiful, curious, thoughtful, compassionate episode. It's like a mini shot in the arm of self-belief and dignity and respect and self-compassion. And I think you are going to love it. If you do, please do like, please do comment, please do subscribe. If you're listening as a podcast, please do follow the show. It's the kindest thing you can do for any content creator that you rate.
这次经历真正帮助她体现了她所实践和倡导的一切。这是一集优美、充满好奇、深思熟虑且富有同情心的节目。它就像一剂关于自信、尊严、尊重和自我同情的强心针。我想你会喜欢的。如果你喜欢，请点赞、评论并订阅。如果你是在听播客，请关注这个节目。这是你能为你所欣赏的内容创作者所做的最贴心的事。
Let's crash on, let's meet Kelly. And yeah, I just think it's a great episode and I hope you agree too. I will catch you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome along our guest for today, Kelly Marie Loveseat. Hi Kelly, welcome along. Hi Marianne. So we have known one another since we were 11 years old, haven't we? Yeah, I drove past our secondary school the other day as I went to visit somebody in the
让我们继续，来见见凯利。是的，我认为这是一集很棒的节目，希望你也同意。稍后见。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾，凯利·玛丽·洛夫西特。嗨，凯利，欢迎你。嗨，玛丽安。我们从11岁起就认识了，对吧？是的，前几天我去村里拜访某人时开车经过了我们的中学，
village and realised it had been far more years than I'd given it credit for. Yeah, won't disclose exactly how many years. Well, maybe we will. I'm 43, you're 44. You're one of the old ones, weren't you? You're one of the September babies. I was, but it was good at the time because you were always the oldest in the year. Now I would probably be the youngest. Okay, so we have stayed in touch. We have seen each other over the years, but recently you shared a Facebook post that was really honest and really resonated with me. And it was around the theme of, oh, I started a new job. I realized it was not for me for a variety of reasons. And rather than kind of grin and bear it, kind of wallow in that pain, or make the best of a bad situation,
意识到距离那时已经过去比我预想中多得多的年头了。是的，就不透露具体多少年了。好吧，也许我们可以透露。我43岁，你44岁。你是大姐姐那一拨的，对吧？你是9月份出生的。我是，但当时感觉很好，因为你总是同年级里最大的。现在我可能就是最小的了。好吧，我们一直保持联系。这些年来我们见过面，但最近你在Facebook上分享了一篇非常诚实且引起我共鸣的帖子。主题是关于“哦，我开始了一份新工作，由于各种原因，我意识到它不适合我”。与其忍气吞声、沉溺于痛苦中，或者在糟糕的情况下凑合，
you decided a different course of action, didn't you? Could you guide us through that? Yeah, absolutely. So actually what had happened was, I'd worked in a company that I loved, absolutely loved. I loved my staff, we built the culture, and it was beautiful. And then the client base was sold,
你选择了不同的行动方针，对吧？你能带我们了解一下吗？是的，绝对可以。其实发生的事情是，我曾在一家我热爱的公司工作，真的非常热爱。我爱我的员工，我们共同建立了企业文化，那非常美好。后来客户群被出售了，
and we had to make all of our staff redundant. So I needed to find a new job. So firstly, I wasn't looking. And I think sometimes that's part of it is you aren't looking, so you aren't necessarily taking your own needs into account. So I went and found another job that seemed on the surface like it would be the ideal job that I was looking for. But what actually happened is I realized I'd stay quite quickly within six weeks. That perhaps the business wasn't a fit for me, but I hadn't quite figured out in that six weeks why that was. So I decided I would stay. Maybe it was just nerves, maybe it was somewhere different. And that actually six weeks isn't a very long time to get used to somewhere. But by the time we got to the end of 12 weeks, I had changed from being outgoing, talkative, excited, shiny, even to being sad, flat, tired.
我们不得不裁掉所有员工。所以我需要找一份新工作。首先，我当时并没有在找工作。我认为这有时是问题的一部分，因为你不是主动在找，所以你不一定会考虑到自己的需求。于是我找了另一份工作，表面上看它似乎是我正在寻找的理想工作。但实际上，我在六周内就很快意识到，这家企业可能并不适合我，但在那六周里我还没完全弄明白原因。所以我决定留下来。也许只是紧张，也许是因为环境不同。而且六周的时间对于适应一个新地方来说确实不长。但到了第12周时，我已经从一个外向、健谈、兴奋、闪闪发光的人，变成了一个悲伤、平淡、疲惫的人。
And there were two things that fundamentally changed it for me. One, I did a day trip to Paris on my own. And I walked around Paris and I had this moment where I realized that I deserved to be really happy and I wasn't. And it was quite empowering. And then I went to Amsterdam for work, but for a conference. And I did some presenting and some hosting and it kind of relit the fire of who I am. So I came back and spent a week evaluating what was it that didn't work for me in the place that I moved to, realized that fundamentally their culture and my needs were never going to balance out. And I took the decision to set up my own company, hand my notice in and see where things took
有两件事从根本上改变了我的想法。第一，我独自去巴黎进行了一次一日游。我在巴黎漫步时，突然意识到我理应过得非常快乐，但我并没有。这让我感到很有力量。然后我因为工作去了阿姆斯特丹参加会议。我做了一些演讲和主持工作，这重新点燃了我内心的火焰。所以我回来后花了一周时间评估我搬到的那个地方到底哪里不适合我，意识到从根本上讲，他们的文化和我的需求永远无法平衡。于是我决定创办自己的公司，递交了辞呈，看看事情会把我带向
me and we find ourselves here. So we do. And, you know, I mentioned in the comment on your post that actually I thought this would make a really powerful podcast episode. And I know that is potentially feels quite exposing and quite new. But this is not something that doesn't happen to anyone else. You know, this can be more common than we think. And I love your, your story of curiosity and reflection. And there was no judgment there that you applied to yourself. There was no shame. It was like, oh, oh, I've noticed this thing. And actually, that's not helping me live towards
哪里，然后我们就到了这里。确实。而且，你知道，我在你帖子的评论中提到，其实我认为这会成为一期非常有影响力的播客节目。我知道这可能感觉相当暴露且相当新鲜。但这并不是什么罕见的事。你知道，这比我们想象的要普遍得多。我喜欢你那种好奇和反思的故事。你对自己没有任何评判。没有羞耻感。就像是，“哦，我注意到了这一点。实际上，这并不能帮助我实现
my values, which are actually all of these things. And so rather than fix myself, mould myself, mould myself to fit this situation, I'm actually going to do what I can within my control to make a change. And for you, that change was taking yourself out of that situation, letting that culture, that organisation carry on as they are, because it wasn't important to you to change that. It was just important that you recognised that was not a bit of you and it was not helping you thrive. No, and I love to change cultures. In my previous place, we took what was quite a challenging environment and we built this amazing, amazing thing. And I would have loved to do that there, but not everywhere is open to the sorts of culture that I love to work in. And so it's
我的价值观，而我的价值观其实是这些东西。”所以，与其修复自己、塑造自己以适应这种情况，我不如在我的控制范围内尽我所能做出改变。对你来说，这种改变就是让自己脱离那种环境，让那种文化、那个组织继续保持原样，因为改变它对你来说并不重要。重要的是你认识到那不是你的菜，它无助于你的成长。不，我喜欢改变文化。在我之前的地方，我们将一个相当具有挑战性的环境打造成了非常了不起的东西。我很乐意在那里也这样做，但并非每个地方都对我也喜欢的工作文化持开放态度。所以，
not for me to pass judgment on that culture, but it is for me to go, if it can't fit with my, it's not your morals, is it? Because that makes it sound a bit sketchy. But there's a part of you inside that you go, this is, this is the level that I can, I can deal with. And there's the professional side, but also I'm a human with a family and needs and requirements myself and this is killing me. And so now I feel unfulfilled in both elements of my life and my partner, my kids, my dog, myself, we don't deserve and no amount of money is worth feeling not the best version of yourself.
我无权对那种文化进行评判，但我必须说，如果它不能与我的——这不是你的道德准则，对吧？因为那样听起来有点可疑。但你内心深处有一部分会说，这是我能承受的底线。这不仅是职业层面，我还是一个有家庭、有需求的人，这正在摧毁我。所以现在我在生活的两个方面都感到不满足，我的伴侣、我的孩子、我的狗，还有我自己，我们不应该这样，没有任何金钱值得让你感觉自己不是最好的版本。
So yeah, it was, I did feel frightened. I don't wanna sit here like the most confident person that ever did live and go, this was super easy for me. When I did it, my insides went, oh, okay. But the overriding feeling was, I was really proud of myself. And I'm also very fortunate because I was made redundant. I have a bit of a financial security that not everybody has. So I also do recognise that
所以是的，我确实感到害怕。我不想坐在这里表现得像个有史以来最自信的人，说这对我来说超级容易。当我做决定时，我的内心在说，“哦，好吧。”但压倒性的感觉是，我为自己感到非常自豪。而且我也很幸运，因为我被裁员了，我有一定的经济保障，这是不是每个人都有的。所以我也承认
I was able to move potentially quicker than some other people may be able to do because of their financial needs and requirements. But the advice still stands in that you can do things over a period of time, but just have your plan in place. I was just really fortunate that I was able to think mine through, make a plan and enact it quite quickly. But just because you can't enact it quickly doesn't mean you shouldn't enact it. You just have to do again what works for you in your circumstances. And I was really, really fortunate and I'm very excited. And I think if something excites you, you should definitely explore it.
我能够比其他人更快地采取行动，因为他们的经济需求和要求不同。但建议依然有效，你可以分阶段去做，但一定要有计划。我只是非常幸运，能够把事情想清楚，制定计划并很快付诸实施。但这并不意味着如果你不能快速实施就不应该实施。你只需要根据自己的情况做适合你的事。我真的非常非常幸运，而且我感到非常兴奋。我认为如果某件事让你感到兴奋，你绝对应该去探索它。
Absolutely. And I think it's, you know, really, even as we spoke before we hit record, this has really activated your drive system. And actually, what you nicely demonstrated with your hands like that is a psychology term called cognitive dissonance. It's that actually, they were there, you were here, and the amount of psychological effort and shift it would take for you to... Maybe if you were really hating it and you were up here and they were down there, the amount of effort it would take you for bringing yourself to their level because they aren't going to move, will potentially break you. We've all got ability to do a little bit of this, but actually if you're always having
绝对是这样。而且我认为，甚至在我们录音前交谈时，这确实激活了你的驱动系统。实际上，你刚才用手势很好地展示了一个心理学术语，叫“认知失调”。实际上，他们在那儿，你在这儿，你需要付出的心理努力和转变才能……也许如果你真的很讨厌它，你在上面，他们在下面，你为了把自己提升到他们的水平而付出的努力，因为他们不会改变，可能会摧毁你。我们都有能力做一点这种调整，但实际上如果你总是
to do this or always having to do that, it's an indication that this is probably not the right space for you. Yeah. I've tried to, and I'm not always the best at this because sometimes life takes over, but you can only control what you can control. Right? I can't control other people, not really, not properly. So I can only control what's within my sphere of influence. So that's where I can make the changes.
不得不这样做，或者总是不得不那样做，这表明这可能不是适合你的空间。是的。我试过，而且我并不总是擅长这一点，因为有时生活会接管一切，但你只能控制你能控制的事情。对吧？我无法控制别人，不是真的，不是彻底地。所以我只能控制我影响范围内的事情。这就是我可以做出改变的地方。
And if other things around me change as a result of that positively, then I love that and it actually brings me so much joy. But I've learned that I need to concentrate on what I'm capable of changing. And you do that with morality. And I very much believe, saying that I use all the time, is lighting somebody else's candle doesn't make the room darker, it makes it brighter,
如果周围的其他事情因此而积极改变，那么我很高兴，这确实给我带来了很多快乐。但我学会了需要专注于我有能力改变的事情。你用道德来做到这一点。我非常相信我一直说的一句话：点亮别人的蜡烛并不会让房间变暗，反而会让它更亮，
and it does not take away from your light. So I try and live that way. And I think if you bring your intention into those sorts of decisions, you don't hurt other people because that's the other thing is I wanted to make all of these changes, but I did not want to hurt anybody's feelings. I did not want to cause discomfort to anybody, even the the company that I decided to leave.
而且这不会夺走你的光芒。所以我试着那样生活。我认为如果你把意图带入这些决定中，你就不会伤害别人，因为另一件事是，我想做出所有这些改变，但我不想伤害任何人的感情。我不想给任何人造成不适，即使是对我决定离开的公司。
I wish them all the best. And I genuinely believe in what they're trying to do. So I think you can exit out of situations with as much dignity as you can. That helps you not feel embarrassed or stressed and proud of yourself. Again, you can control your own behaviour and that's really important when you take these decisions. Yeah. And I know that people's CVs and gaps on their CV, but also how long you've spent at a company can feel like you're going to get that apprentice Alan Sugar question, why were you only there two months or what were you doing during that time? You need to feel like you've got to validate that.
我祝愿他们一切顺利。我真诚地相信他们正在努力做的事情。所以我认为你可以尽可能体面地退出某种情况。这有助于你不感到尴尬或压力，并为你自己感到自豪。同样，你可以控制自己的行为，当你做出这些决定时，这一点非常重要。是的。我知道人们的简历和简历上的空白期，以及你在一家公司待了多久，可能会让你觉得你会遇到那种艾伦·休格式的质问：“为什么你只在那里待了两个月？”或者“那段时间你在做什么？”你需要感觉自己必须验证这一点。
Sometimes especially people in aspiring psych roles might say to me, I feel like I need to be there for at least six months. I'm like, well, it seems to be killing you. Do you really? What about those shoulds, Kelly, and the values that we apply to ourselves, but we think that we need to kind of live up to as well. Could we talk to that? Oh, 100%. So, all right, if you've got six jobs that you've only been in three months, people are going to start to question your commitment and actually you have to start questioning your commitment or your evaluation processes before you take jobs. But we're not talking about five or six.
有时，特别是那些有抱负的心理学职位的人可能会对我说：“我觉得我至少需要在那里待六个月。”我说：“好吧，它似乎正在摧毁你。你真的需要吗？”凯利，关于那些“应该”以及我们对自己应用但认为自己也需要达到的价值观，我们能谈谈吗？哦，百分之百。好吧，如果你有六份工作都只待了三个月，人们就会开始质疑你的承诺，实际上你必须开始质疑你的承诺或你在接受工作之前的评估过程。但我们谈论的不是五六份。
If you've got one, the thing that you, I was going to say need, but it's not a need again, those shoulds again, isn't it? Is you have to find your narrative and get comfortable with that. And also I think now, do I want to work for somewhere where I can't be honest about the fact that a place wasn't right for me and I made a decision that was right for me, but I am committed to being at the right place? Look at the rest of my CV where I've been at places six years, seven years,
如果你只有一份，你需要——我本来想说“需要”，但那又是一个“需要”，又是那些“应该”，对吧？你必须找到你的叙事并对此感到自在。而且我也认为，现在，我是否想为那种我无法诚实地说出“某个地方不适合我，我做出了对我正确的决定，但我致力于在正确的地方工作”的地方工作？看看我简历的其他部分，我在某些地方待了六年、七年，
been made redundant from my last role that I loved or I'd have stayed. So these shoulds that we put in place, I think we have to separate them out. Some we put on ourselves and some we should. We should be a good person and we shouldn't be hurting other people's feelings unnecessarily. Those are some quite solid shoulds. We need to pay our mortgage or we need to pay our bills. So sometimes there are practical applications that need to take over. They are a should. Again, you can't really control that to a degree, but I should be somewhere for six months. I like to challenge with evidence. Where's the evidence for that? Where are all the studies that show six months gives you such a better evaluation period than four? Or that a workplace won't judge you just as harshly for leaving after six months? Because six months
从我上一份我热爱的角色中被裁员，否则我会留下来。所以这些我们设置的“应该”，我认为我们必须把它们分开。有些是我们强加给自己的，有些是我们应该做的。我们应该做一个好人，我们不应该无谓地伤害别人的感情。这些是一些相当坚实的“应该”。我们需要支付抵押贷款或账单。所以有时会有需要接管的实际应用。它们是一个“应该”。同样，你在一定程度上无法真正控制它，但“我应该在一个地方待六个月”。我喜欢用证据来挑战。证据在哪里？哪里有研究表明六个月比四个月给你更好的评估期？或者职场不会因为你六个月后离开而同样严厉地评判你？因为六个月
still isn't very long. We shackle ourselves sometimes and women do it more. There's a really interesting stat that says men will apply for jobs if they are 20% capable of the stuff that's in the job description. Women will likely, this is all likelihood, wait until they're 80% capable of doing the job. And it's part of the reason why men have moved forward faster than women. Part of it's been all the things that have gone on in history, but they have this ability to not always take on what everybody else thinks when it comes to their jobs. So they have been historically, and again this sounds maybe a bit sexist, but it isn't. It's based on studies, is that we would do better looking at ourselves a bit more like that. What do
仍然不是很长。我们有时会束缚自己，女性更是如此。有一个非常有趣的统计数据说，如果男性有20%的能力胜任职位描述中的内容，他们就会申请工作。女性很可能会——这都是可能性——等到她们有80%的能力胜任工作时才申请。这就是为什么男性比女性进步更快的部分原因。部分原因是历史上发生的所有事情，但他们有一种能力，在工作方面并不总是接受别人的想法。所以从历史上看，这听起来可能有点性别歧视，但事实并非如此。它是基于研究的，我们如果能多像那样看待自己，会做得更好。我
I deserve? Not what does the other company deserve because I'll give them the very best of me. What do I deserve? Not what should I do? I've got enough shoulds in my life, I've got kids. You know, there's a lot that you need to do there. But this is the biggest should. You should be able to be happy at work. That sounds like a really obvious sentence, doesn't it? But the question that you asked me indicates that actually too many people don't put that should at the very top of their list. And my last role before the one that I didn't love, I had 120 staff, right? If they weren't happy, I wasn't getting the best of them.
值得什么？不是另一家公司值得什么，因为我会给他们我最好的。我值得什么？不是我应该做什么？我的生活中已经有足够的“应该”了，我有孩子。你知道，你需要做的事情很多。但这是最大的“应该”。你应该能够在工作中感到快乐。这听起来是一句非常显而易见的话，不是吗？但我问你的问题表明，实际上太多人没有把这个“应该”放在他们清单的最顶端。在我上一份我不喜欢的工作之前，我有120名员工，对吧？如果他们不快乐，我就无法得到他们最好的一面。
If my voice was the only path forward, they weren't able to be creative. You have to create an environment for your staff, for yourself, that allows you to fail fast and safely. We get the best results by putting ourselves in situations that make us slightly uncomfortable because we push. But create an environment for yourself
如果我的声音是唯一的前进道路，他们就无法发挥创造力。你必须为你的员工、为你自己创造一个环境，让你能够快速且安全地失败。我们通过让自己处于让我们稍微不舒服的情况中来获得最好的结果，因为我们推动了自己。但为你自己创造一个环境，
where it's okay if it goes wrong. Like, Marion, if I'd come to you and said, I really hate my job and, you know, the advice you would have given me, what I imagine would have been along the lines of, you deserve better, Kelly, and you deserve to be happy. So would we have been as likely to give that same advice to ourselves, do you think? Yeah, yeah, absolutely. And actually how we speak to ourselves can often be a sense of how others have spoken to us. So if we've been around lots of messages that like, no, other people will think this or that, then we begin to internalize that ourselves. But I loved what you said. We deserve to be happy at work. We're going to be there like 40, 50, 60 years. Exactly. 152 years if they keep raising the retirement age, you and I'll be working till
如果事情出错也没关系。比如，玛丽安，如果我来找你说，我真的很讨厌我的工作，你知道，你会给我的建议，我想会是这样的：“你值得更好的，凯利，你值得快乐。”那么你认为我们会同样可能给对自己提出同样的建议吗？是的，是的，绝对。而且实际上我们对自己说话的方式往往是别人对我们说话方式的一种体现。所以如果我们周围有很多信息说，“不，别人会这样或那样想”，那么我们就会开始内化这一点。但我喜欢你说的。我们值得在工作中快乐。我们要在那儿待40、50、60年。没错。如果他们继续提高退休年龄，就是152年，你和我将工作到
we die. But you do deserve to be happy. But also if your workplace puts a lot of effort into making sure you're happy, they also deserve the best of you. And it becomes this mutually beneficial relationship where everybody wins. You know, like a win-win-win situation. And the more of those that we can create in life, the better off people are generally. I do quite a lot of coaching with women. And one of the first things I try to get them to do is when we talk, they're like, I think. I went, do you think or do you know? Let's have an honest conversation. So by saying I think, we almost, as you said, we're putting doubt, self-doubt on ourselves or not demonstrating to others
我们死。但你确实值得快乐。而且如果你的工作场所投入大量精力确保你快乐，他们也值得你最好的一面。这变成了一种互惠互利的关系，每个人都是赢家。你知道，就像一种三赢的局面。我们在生活中创造的这种局面越多，人们总体上就越好。我做了很多女性教练工作。我试图让她们做的第一件事是，当我们交谈时，她们说“我想”。我说，你是“想”还是“知道”？让我们进行一次诚实的对话。所以通过说“我想”，我们几乎，正如你所说，我们在对自己施加怀疑，或者没有向别人展示
that we have conviction in the things that we're saying. So one of the very first things we can do is I will self-correct. If I am in the middle of a sentence, I go, I think this, I will stop and I will go, actually, I know this to be the case. So I'll use I think when I only think it, but I've tried over the last few years where I've worked really hard to build up confidence in myself and others to recognise that even small things like I think or maybe I could, am I feeling that way or am I trying to make myself not too much for somebody, to project a less confident exterior so that other people can be comfortable. I'm outgoing and I'm quite outspoken, but I can have a filter where it's needed. So I won't filter
我们对自己所说的事情有信念。所以我们可以做的第一件事就是自我纠正。如果我在句子中间说“我想这个”，我会停下来，然后说“实际上，我知道情况就是这样”。所以我只在真正认为的时候才用“我想”，但我过去几年里努力工作，建立对自己和他人的信心，认识到即使是像“我想”或“也许我可以”这样的小事，我是那种感觉，还是我在试图让自己不要对某人来说“太多”，为了投射一个不那么自信的外表，以便让别人感到舒服。我很外向，而且相当直言不讳，但我可以在需要时设置过滤器。所以我不会过滤
everything I say. I will in the right environments, but I've learned that actually I might not be for everybody. And whilst I don't want anybody to dislike me or hate me, it's okay that I'm not for everybody. I'm not for every workplace. Every I'm not for everybody. I'm not for every workplace. Every workplace is not for me. I'm not for them. Getting a bit comfortable with not having to be loved and adored by everybody. Actually, you get this freedom
我说的每一句话。在合适的环境下我会，但我学会了实际上我可能并不适合所有人。虽然我不希望任何人不喜欢我或讨厌我，但我不适合所有人是可以的。我不适合每个人。我不适合每个工作场所。每个工作场所也不适合我。我不适合他们。习惯于不必被所有人爱戴和崇拜。实际上，你得到了这种自由，
that you still gotta be a good human. So you can't go around being a horrible person and go, it doesn't matter because I don't care if people like me. But actually saying to yourself if I've been the truest version of me and that hasn't worked, two choices here, stay, change and you get to pick a lane. But I'm really fortunate that I've had excellent support. You mentioned my Facebook post. That post made me cry. Not because of what I'd written,
你仍然必须是一个好人。所以你不能到处做一个糟糕的人，然后说“没关系，因为我不在乎别人是否喜欢我”。但实际上对自己说，如果我已经做了最真实的自己，而那没有奏效，这里有两个选择：留下，改变，你可以选择一条路。但我真的很幸运，我得到了极好的支持。你提到了我的Facebook帖子。那篇帖子让我哭了。不是因为我写了什么，
because I was really comfortable with what I'd written, but the support that I received underneath, in the comments from people who I'd helped or people who'd watched me grow, properly brought tears to my eyes. While I was in the middle of Disneyland Parish, you understand as well, so that was a weird situation. But you're putting yourself out there's really,
因为我对写的内容感到非常自在，而是因为我在评论区收到的支持，来自我帮助过的人或看着我成长的人，真的让我热泪盈眶。当时我还在巴黎迪士尼乐园中间，你也明白，所以那是一个奇怪的情况。但你把自己展现出来真的
really hard. But if you do it and you do it in the right way, actually people are fundamentally good. When you speak in front of people, for the most part, they don't want you to fail. They don't want you to not do well, they want you to grow. So I think we need to sometimes work on being more comfortable with talking about achievements or things that we've done like deciding to set up our own company without feeling that we've also got to maybe belittle ourselves a bit just to make sure people don't feel uncomfortable with that. That's quite interesting. And from a psychological perspective, I'm sure there's some very technical terms for it, but I do a lot of work on imposter syndrome and helping especially women identify that
非常困难。但如果你做了，而且以正确的方式做，实际上人们本质上是善良的。当你站在人们面前说话时，在大多数情况下，他们不希望你失败。他们不希望你做得不好，他们希望你成长。所以我认为我们有时需要努力让自己更习惯于谈论成就或我们做过的事情，比如决定创办自己的公司，而不觉得我们也必须稍微贬低自己，只是为了确保人们不会对此感到不舒服。这很有趣。从心理学角度来看，我相信有一些非常专业的术语，但我做了很多关于冒名顶替综合症的工作，帮助特别是女性识别出
that is a big driver and sometimes why we don't do things. So I would also urge people to do a bit of research on imposter syndrome. It's really interesting actually how the mind works in those instances, but there are some really easy techniques that you can use to make sure that even if you're inside feels it, you're outside is able to not show it as much. And you do that a few times and then you're actually confident about it. It's the bit fake it till you make it, but there's nothing wrong with that. That's been going on since the dawn of time, you know, but don't break yourself to do it and be authentic with it.
这是一个巨大的驱动力，有时也是我们不做事情的原因。所以我也会敦促人们对冒名顶替综合症做一些研究。在这些情况下，大脑的工作方式确实非常有趣，但有一些非常简单的技巧，你可以使用，以确保即使你的内心感觉到了，你的外表也能尽量不表现出来。你这样做几次，然后你实际上就对此充满自信了。这就是“假装直到你成功”，但这没什么错。这从开天辟地以来就一直在发生，你知道，但不要为了做到这一点而摧毁自己，并保持真实。
Yeah, absolutely. And yeah, just allow yourself to feel, we don't want you to feel overwhelmed, but having a gentle stretch, that feels good sometimes and actually allows us to then more comfortably grow. And so it's yeah, just thinking about actually being well supported during your growth phase. Like you said, you know, people around you, maybe it's, you know, people in your network, people in your family, maybe your friends, maybe even people you meet along the way who are also carving out this space
是的，绝对。而且是的，只是允许自己去感受，我们不希望你感到不知所措，但进行一次温和的伸展，有时感觉很好，实际上让我们能够更舒适地成长。所以是的，只是考虑在你的成长阶段得到良好的支持。就像你说的，你知道，你周围的人，也许是，你知道，你网络里的人，你家庭里的人，也许是你的朋友，甚至是你沿途遇到的人，他们也在开辟这个空间，
that you use them appropriately to help you to get where you need to be. And then like you say, you help the other people coming up behind you as well. Do not tread on people to get where you need to go. OK, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, absolutely. And some of what you were saying, it made me think about when you break up with somebody and you don't hate them, but you recognise that actually
你适当地利用他们来帮助你到达你需要去的地方。然后就像你说的，你也帮助在你身后上来的人。不要为了到达你需要去的地方而践踏别人。好的，是的，是的，是的，是的，绝对。而且你所说的一些话，让我想起当你和某人分手时，你不恨他们，但你认识到实际上
I'm not as happy as I think I could be, which therefore means you are not as happy. Even if you tell me you're happy, you are not as happy as I think you have the potential to be. Because if I was really, really, really happy, you would be even happier. And so I want that for you, but I also want that for myself. And I think the same is true of workplaces. If you're there middling along, hating every minute, looking at when it's one minute past five so you can run away, that's not helping the organization to thrive either. Even though recruitment can be a costly, lengthy, involved process, ultimately, it's better to kind of make those decisions that serve you better, that then help you to thrive going off in that direction and the organization to thrive,
我并不像我认为的那样快乐，这因此意味着你也不快乐。即使你告诉我你很快乐，你也不像我认为你有可能的那样快乐。因为如果我真的、真的、真的很快乐，你会更快乐。所以我为你想要那个，但我也为我自己想要那个。我认为工作场所也是如此。如果你在那里混日子，讨厌每一分钟，看着什么时候是五点零一分，这样你就可以逃跑，那对组织的繁荣也没有帮助。即使招聘可能是一个昂贵、漫长、复杂的过程，归根结底，做出那些更好地服务于你的决定，从而帮助你朝着那个方向蓬勃发展，并帮助组织蓬勃发展，
getting someone new in. And maybe they can even get someone that was part of the previous recruitment to, you know, rather than starting again, who then does really thrive and helps the organization to get where it wants to go? Oh, I couldn't agree more. And what I would like to say is there are options. So I didn't just decide I hated it and just quit. And I'm not very much of a quitter, but a lot of organizations are willing to look at new ways of doing things.
招募新人进来，这更好。也许他们甚至可以招募到之前招聘过程中的一部分人，你知道，而不是重新开始，他们反而真的蓬勃发展，并帮助组织实现它想要的目标？哦，我完全同意。我想说的是，有很多选择。所以我并没有仅仅因为我讨厌它就辞职。我不是一个轻易放弃的人，但很多组织愿意考虑新的做事方式。
So being able to verbalize what you would like to see change and offering to help make that change is a really important step, but you can't flog a dead horse. So there is a level, but you know, a lot of junior staff especially feel like they don't have the voice, but most workplaces do have staff forums,
所以能够表达你希望看到什么改变，并主动提出帮助做出这种改变是一个非常重要的步骤，但你不能鞭打死马。所以有一个限度，但你知道，很多初级员工特别觉得他们没有发言权，但大多数工作场所确实有员工论坛、
staff engagement surveys, then people will raise their eyebrows, but oh god I've got to fill another one of those out. So you do need to also recognise where your organisation is trying to make change and if you want things to change you can either moan about it and do nothing or you can step in. Most places now have women's groups, neurodiversity groups, colleague resource groups. Be part of the change. If you don't like something, you do have that option to be part of the process that improves things. But it's important because moaning doesn't improve things. You can verbalise what is incorrect, but you need
员工敬业度调查，然后人们会挑眉毛，“哦天哪，我又要填一份那个了”。所以你也需要认识到你的组织在哪里试图做出改变，如果你想让事情改变，你可以抱怨它并什么都不做，或者你可以介入。现在大多数地方都有女性小组、神经多样性小组、同事资源小组。成为改变的一部分。如果你不喜欢某件事，你确实有选择成为改善事情的过程的一部分。但这很重要，因为抱怨并不能改善事情。你可以表达什么是错误的，但你需要
to also be able to verbalise what maybe you would do differently in order to make a change. I always say to my staff when I take them on, I don't have very many rules, right? Because I think rules are for driving. Okay. So one is please don't lie to me if something goes wrong, because one, I will find out and two, you'll make more of a mess trying to clean it up and then I won't trust you. Tell me and we'll work our way through together. If we keep making that mistake, we're going to have to address it. And the second one is be honest. And I don't mean as in you did something wrong. If things aren't working for you please tell me. But with your honesty I'd also like a suggestion. So I don't have to be right all the time. I'm not the queen of the world. So my, you know, my team have the right to be heard.
也能够表达你可能会做些什么不同的事情来做出改变。我招募员工时总是对他们说，我没有太多规则，对吧？因为我认为规则是给开车用的。好的。所以第一条是，如果出了问题，请不要对我撒谎，因为第一，我会发现，第二，你会试图清理它时弄得更糟，然后我就不会信任你了。告诉我，我们会一起解决。如果我们继续犯那个错误，我们将不得不处理它。第二条是诚实。我不是指你做错了什么。如果事情对你不奏效，请告诉我。但对于你的诚实，我也想要一个建议。所以我不需要一直是对的。我不是世界女王。所以我的，你知道，我的团队有被倾听的权利。
But I also need to know what you would do differently because telling me you hate my idea but having no other way of achieving it doesn't help. And also that can be quite combative. Actually approaching it with, I hear what you're saying, I have an alternative thought process I'd love to be able to discuss with you, maybe we can find a middle ground. You know, also it's not this idea or that idea. Usually the best idea is this one that hasn't been invented yet, which is a combination of pulling in. The other top tip for me, and I can't stress this enough, is do not surround yourself with people who are the same as you. Groupthink is a dangerous, dangerous, dangerous space. I mean, if you want to surround yourself watching people watching, you know, Love is Blind on Netflix, super cool, you need like-minded
但我还需要知道你会做些什么不同的事情，因为告诉我你讨厌我的想法但没有其他实现它的方法并没有帮助。而且这可能相当具有对抗性。实际上以“我听到了你在说什么，我有一个我想和你讨论的替代思维过程，也许我们可以找到一个中间立场”的方式来处理它。你知道，也不是这个想法或那个想法。通常最好的想法是这个尚未被发明的想法，它是结合了……的组合。对我来说的另一个顶级建议，我怎么强调都不为过，就是不要让自己被和你一样的人包围。群体思维是一个危险、危险、危险的空间。我的意思是，如果你想让自己被看电视的人包围，你知道，在Netflix上看《爱情盲选》，超级酷，你需要志同道合的
people, it's a fun time. If you want to create a brilliant atmosphere, so I'm very extroverted, which won't be a surprise to anybody I imagine on this podcast, but how do I bring introverts into discussion points and make sure they're heard? It's my responsibility to set an agenda that allows them space to be spoken to. I can ask probing questions if I feel that they're struggling to verbalize it. I don't just, now they've gone quiet, I just let it go. So surround yourself with diversity. And I mean that in all shapes and forms. You can have the classic ones if you're a man, you're a woman, you're older, you're younger, you're black, you're white. But I mean, people who
的人，那是一段有趣的时光。如果你想创造一种辉煌的氛围，所以我非常外向，我想在这个播客上对任何人来说都不会感到惊讶，但我如何将内向者带入讨论点并确保他们被听到？我有责任设定一个议程，让他们有空间被交谈。如果我觉得他们难以表达，我可以提出探究性的问题。我不会只是，现在他们安静了，我就让它过去。所以用多样性包围自己。我的意思是各种形式的多样性。你可以有经典的，如果你是男人，你是女人，你更老，你更年轻，你是黑人，你是白人。但我的意思是，那些
think differently to you. It's the most enriching experience. My partner is Jamaican. We've been together 18 years. And prior to that, I had no understanding of that culture whatsoever. The moment I dipped my toe in the water I loved it and I have learned so many new things. I can cook different dishes, I listen to entirely different music that's become some of my favourite because I didn't just end up surrounding myself with more people who are like me and that can be frightening for some people. So if you're one that's able to do that, just spare a minute to try and create an environment for others who maybe can't do that with such ease.
想法和你不同的人。这是最丰富的体验。我的伴侣是牙买加人。我们在一起18年了。在此之前，我对那种文化一无所知。当我涉足其中的那一刻，我爱上了它，我学到了很多新东西。我可以做不同的菜，我听完全不同的音乐，这已经成为我最喜欢的音乐之一，因为我没有最终只让自己被更多像我一样的人包围，这对某些人来说可能很可怕。所以如果你是一个能够做到这一点的人，请花一分钟时间尝试为那些可能无法如此轻松做到这一点的人创造一个环境。
And I've done a lot of mentoring and I tend to mentor introverts because they're the ones who want, I've tried to explain to people extroversion also isn't just about being outgoing. So I'm actually more of an ambivert these days. So I fling between two, but I'll crash out if I'm not careful. And that's something I have to learn to manage. I'm not very
我做了很多指导工作，我倾向于指导内向者，因为他们是那些想要……我试图向人们解释，外向性也不仅仅是关于外向。所以我现在其实更像是一个双向性格者。所以我在两者之间摇摆，但如果我不小心，我会崩溃。这是我必须学会管理的事情。我不太
good at that, by the way. But introversion and extroversion has a lot to do with where you get your energy from, right? So this conversation will have energised me because I'm an extrovert. We will leave this and I'll be energised for the day. An introvert will have maybe enjoyed it loads, but need to go and have a moment on their own or maybe an hour. So, recognising that if you're doing a whole day event and you've got a load of introverts in there, you need lots of breaks and you probably need some food. But, you know, adjusting things, it creates the culture and that kind of centrally brings us, doesn't it, back around to this whole culture of the workplace. We're all responsible for it.
擅长那个，顺便说一句。但内向和外向与你从哪里获得能量有很大关系，对吧？所以这次谈话会让我充满活力，因为我是外向者。我们将离开这里，我这一天都会充满活力。一个内向者可能非常享受它，但需要去独自待一会儿，或者也许一个小时。所以，认识到如果你正在进行一整天的活动，并且里面有一堆内向者，你需要大量的休息，而且你可能需要一些食物。但是，你知道，调整事情，它创造了文化，这在某种程度上把我们带回了职场的整个文化，对吧？我们都对此负责。
The big boss is not the only one responsible for culture because they can't do it on their own. They have to demonstrate the culture and verbalize the culture and create an environment for it. But it's everybody's job in the workplace to work towards that culture. So yeah, honestly, diversity is one of the biggest plus points to a workplace culture that I've ever found because it's so exciting to hear viewpoints you'd have never thought of yourself.
大老板不是唯一对文化负责的人，因为他们无法独自完成。他们必须展示文化、表达文化并为之创造环境。但职场中的每个人都有责任为那种文化而努力。所以是的，老实说，多样性是我发现的职场文化中最大的加分项之一，因为听到你自己从未想过的观点是如此令人兴奋。
Yeah, I love that. And yeah, even before we hit record, we're thinking about, actually, it's really lovely to have friends that are at different stages of their career, different stages of kind of income, of wealth. And like, you know, sometimes you've got a friend who might insist on going first class on a train. Sometimes you might go backpacking and stay in a hostel. Like, it's really useful to have all those different viewpoints in our friendship circles and in our professional and family life as well. Like, I love the idea of, yeah, like finding a tribe who won't just say yes to you, but will challenge you and open you up to be curious and look at things in a different way. Yeah, for sure. So I had a couple of people reach out to me from my post. So my LinkedIn
是的，我喜欢那个。而且是的，甚至在我们录音之前，我们就在想，实际上，拥有处于职业生涯不同阶段、收入和财富不同阶段的朋友真的很可爱。而且就像，你知道，有时你有一个朋友可能坚持在火车上坐头等舱。有时你可能会去背包旅行并住在旅馆里。就像，在我们的朋友圈以及我们的职业和家庭生活中拥有所有这些不同的观点真的很有用。就像，我喜欢这个想法，是的，就像找到一个不会只对你说“是”的部落，而是会挑战你并让你敞开心扉去好奇，并以不同的方式看待事物。是的，当然。所以我从我的帖子中收到了一些人的联系。所以我的LinkedIn
post did not go into any of my emotional requirements. It's not appropriate in my mind for that environment. My Facebook people is full of friends and people I've known throughout my life. But through the Facebook post, a couple of people reached out to me. One of them was my sister. And my sister wasn't enjoying the job that she'd moved to. And she asked for my advice. And I said to her, you already know what I'm going to say. And that's why you've called me. I just quit my job because I was miserable. So that's the advice you know I'm going to give you. You have friends that you can go to who would give you the opposite advice, right? But you haven't gone there. So you already know what you're going to do. So I'm
帖子没有涉及我的任何情感需求。在我看来，这对于那个环境来说是不合适的。我的Facebook上全是朋友和我一生中认识的人。但通过Facebook帖子，有几个人联系了我。其中一个是我的妹妹。我妹妹不喜欢她搬到的那份工作。她征求了我的建议。我对她说：“你已经知道我要说什么了。这就是你给我打电话的原因。我刚刚辞职，因为我很痛苦。所以这就是你知道我会给你的建议。你有朋友可以去找，他们会给你相反的建议，对吧？但你没有去那里。所以你已经知道你要做什么了。所以我
not going to tell you what to do because I'm not. That's not my job. But what I'm going to say to you is you've already told me what you want by reaching out to me." And she was like, oh, and sometimes I needed to be that honest with my sister so I can be as honest as I want with her. But I said to her, like, she needed one of the things you can hand to people when they're struggling with their confidence is the ability to make the decision themselves. So I did. I said, it is your decision.
不会告诉你该做什么，因为我不会。那不是我的工作。但我会告诉你的是，你通过联系我已经告诉了我你想要什么。”她就像，“哦”，有时我需要对我妹妹那么诚实，所以我可以随心所欲地对她诚实。但我对她说，就像，当人们在自信心上挣扎时，你可以给他们的一件事是让他们自己做决定的能力。所以我做了。我说，这是你的决定。
You know what I would do and you know what I did and I would back you whatever and I think you're epic. She's also just built a TikTok page for her plus-sized clothing that's hit 25,000 subscribers. So I said to her, you know you can do things. So she did that. And then another lady reached out to me who was really struggling with her job and she didn't want to quit. I could tell by her message. And it sounded like neither did the company wanted to quit. So I coached her a little bit on what sort of conversations she could go and have. And she did.
你知道我会怎么做，也知道我做了什么，无论如何我都会支持你，我觉得你太棒了。她还刚为自己的大码服装品牌建立了一个TikTok页面，粉丝已经达到了25,000人。所以我对她说，你知道你可以做到的。于是她就去做了。后来，另一位女士联系了我，她在工作中遇到了很大的困难，但她不想辞职。我从她的信息中能看出来。听起来公司也不想让她辞职。所以我指导了她一下，告诉她可以去进行什么样的沟通。她照做了。
And now she's had a promotion out of it and is able to influence things. And is really much happier. And I almost didn't post that because I was like, oh, maybe people think there's some self pity here. And I was like, but there isn't. So it's fine. I like self-regulated that. Ten years ago, I would never have put that post up because I wasn't able to self-regulate that way. But the tribe that you surround yourself with is important, but also take a bit of recognition to say, who did I go to for that? Now, did I go to them because
现在她因此获得了晋升，并且能够发挥影响力了。她真的快乐多了。我差点没发那条动态，因为我在想，哦，也许人们会觉得这有点自怜。但我又想，其实并没有。所以没关系。我对自己进行了自我调节。十年前，我绝不会发布那条动态，因为我当时还无法那样进行自我调节。但你身边的人际圈很重要，同时也要学会认可自己，问问自己：我当时是去找谁寻求帮助的？那么，我去找他们是因为
I had no other choice? That's different. But who are they? And what does that actually mean I wanted from this conversation, really? And give yourself the value you deserve. Yes, my advice is probably going to be great because it's what I do and I'm pretty good at the work stuff and I'm good at the coaching, but nobody knows you like you know you. And so teaching people, again, I do predominantly speak with women, but that's just been, I think, because I did a lot of the women's group stuff. But that bit where you can self-recognize to trust this bit, you know, the little bit in there that speaks but has no mouth. Teaching people to trust that part of their gut, to not assume the worst of themselves, to treat
我别无选择吗？那是不一样的。但他们是谁？这实际上意味着我从这次谈话中真正想要得到什么？给自己应得的价值。是的，我的建议可能很棒，因为这是我的本职工作，我在工作方面很在行，我也擅长辅导，但没有人比你更了解你自己。所以教导人们——再说一次，我主要和女性交谈，但我认为那只是因为我做了很多女性团体的工作——但那个你可以自我识别并信任这一点的部分，你知道，内心那个会说话但没有嘴巴的小声音。教导人们去信任他们的直觉，不要把最坏的情况想在自己身上，去对待
themselves like they would treat their best friend if their best friend was having this conversation with them. You know, don't belittle yourself. People say to me, I'm just so stupid for thinking that. Please don't, please don't. I don't want to hear you're so stupid unless you just did something really stupid. You know, like the other day I put my lipstick in the fridge and I couldn't find it. That was stupid, right? Because I meant to put the butter in the fridge and I don't know what happened. That was silly. But we don't talk about ourselves. I put the pineapple in the cupboard the other day and when I came back to it, I was like, yeah, this pineapple is no longer usable.
自己就像对待最好的朋友一样，如果最好的朋友正在和他们进行这次谈话的话。你知道，不要贬低自己。人们对我说，我真是太蠢了，竟然会那样想。请不要，请不要。我不想听到你说你太蠢了，除非你真的做了什么非常愚蠢的事情。你知道，就像前几天我把口红放进冰箱里，然后找不到了。那很蠢，对吧？因为我本意是想把黄油放进冰箱，我不知道发生了什么。那很傻。但我们不要那样说自己。前几天我把菠萝放进了橱柜，当我回来再看它时，我就想，是的，这个菠萝没法用了。
No, see? That's a silly moment, right? But we can laugh at ourselves for it. But when we're talking about our genuine skill sets, if we don't talk about ourselves with a certain level of care, not even confidence, because that's a whole different thing. And that not everybody has that, but a level of care. You know, it's okay to say, I don't understand this, or I'd like to learn more about that. That's really self care and go, I don't know anything. I'm never going to know anything. Well, what have you just said to yourself? And how would you have felt at 12 if your teacher had said that to you? Pretty crappy, I would say. Can I say that word on your podcast? But you wouldn't have felt empowered, would you? So let's start
不，你看？那是一个傻傻的时刻，对吧？但我们可以为此自嘲。但当我们谈论我们真正的技能时，如果我们不以某种程度的关怀来谈论自己——甚至不是自信，因为那是完全不同的事情。并不是每个人都有那种自信，但至少要有一种关怀。你知道，说“我不明白这一点”或者“我想多了解一下那个”是可以的。那才是真正的自我关怀，而不是说“我什么都不知道，我永远也不会知道任何事情”。好吧，你刚才对自己说了什么？如果你的老师在12岁时对你说过那样的话，你会感觉如何？我想会感觉很糟糕。我能在你的播客里说那个词吗？但你不会感到被赋能，对吧？所以让我们开始
by empowering ourselves, shall we, by being respectful at the very least. You know, and we'll work on all the confidence and building all the other things, but let's respect ourselves enough to speak about ourselves as we deserve, whilst making jokes about putting pineapples in fridges and lipsticks in freezers and all sorts of things, right? But we can do that. But be kind to others and yourself. Don't tread on others as you, you know like I don't know if you've seen the vision where somebody's climbing and either you can have your foot on somebody's head or you can bring people with you on the journey. That's your tribe. If you bring people with you, the loyalty that manifests from that, if you've done it genuinely is second to
通过尊重自己来赋能自己，好吗？至少要做到尊重。你知道，我们会努力建立自信并培养所有其他能力，但让我们尊重自己，以我们应得的方式谈论自己，同时拿把菠萝放进冰箱、把口红放进冷冻室之类的趣事开开玩笑，对吧？但我们可以那样做。要善待他人和自己。不要像……你知道，我不知道你是否见过那种画面，有人在攀爬，你要么可以踩在别人的头上，要么可以带着大家一起前行。那就是你的圈子。如果你带着大家一起走，如果你的行为是真诚的，由此产生的忠诚度是无与伦比的。
none. Some of my colleagues, my ex-colleagues have become genuine friends because we pulled each other along the journey. When one was struggling, the other just stopped, held their hand, metaphorically most of the time, but sometimes physically, and moved us through together. The people you surround yourself with are really, really important. It's not always easy, especially in highly competitive industries. A lot of the stuff I do for aspiring psychs, getting onto doctorate places, sometimes there's only one job if it's an assistant psych job. Then it's really hard because you want to help them, but you also want to help yourself and you want to get there first. I think it becomes easier
我的一些同事，我的前同事，已经成为了真正的朋友，因为我们互相扶持着走过了这段旅程。当一个人遇到困难时，另一个人就会停下来，握住他们的手——大多数时候是隐喻上的，但有时是身体上的——然后带着我们一起度过难关。你身边的人真的非常非常重要。这并不总是容易的，尤其是在竞争激烈的行业中。我为有志于心理学的人做很多工作，帮助他们进入博士点，有时如果是一个助理心理学职位，可能只有一个名额。那时真的很难，因为你想帮助他们，但你也想帮助自己，你想先达到目标。我认为这会变得更容易
when you're going for a role where there might be 15 to 30 to 40 jobs. Oh, absolutely. But yeah, it isn't always easy, but a lot of work I do is around trying to encourage others, bring them along. Don't see them as competition because one day they may be your colleagues, they may still be your best friends ultimately in 15, 20 years. It would be nice to think actually I didn't elbow them in the side, I brought them along with me. And recently there was an idea of someone said they were getting really behind and feeling really overwhelmed and it's actually, no, we are calling you to come and join us where we are. We're not judging you for where you are right now. Like this is your call
当你申请的职位可能有15到30甚至40个名额时。哦，当然。但确实，这并不总是容易的，但我所做的大部分工作都是围绕着鼓励他人，带着他们一起前进。不要把他们视为竞争对手，因为有一天他们可能会成为你的同事，甚至在15、20年后依然是你最好的朋友。想到其实我没有在侧面给他们使绊子，而是带着他们一起前进，这感觉会很好。最近有一个想法，有人说他们落后了很多，感到非常不知所措，其实是，不，我们在呼唤你来加入我们所在的地方。我们不会因为你现在的处境而评判你。就像这是你的呼唤
to step forward. But I think listening to you and your conversation with your sister, you were really empowering herself to give herself permission to make that decision and validating that decision as well. We invalidate ourselves so often. I was talking to a friend the other day who has had a series of awful things happen and was almost like, I don't know why I feel anxious. I don't know why I'm not doing better. And I was like, well, hold on a minute. We had this and this and this. And we've also got this. I wouldn't expect you to be thriving and vibing and living your best self right now.
去向前迈进。但我认为听你和你姐姐的谈话，你真的在赋能她，让她给自己许可去做出那个决定，同时也认可了那个决定。我们经常否定自己。前几天我和一位朋友聊天，她经历了一系列糟糕的事情，几乎就像是说，“我不知道为什么我感到焦虑。我不知道为什么我没有做得更好。”我就说，好吧，等一下。我们经历了这、这和这。而且我们还有这个。我不会指望你现在就能蓬勃发展、充满活力并过上最好的生活。
Like well done for breathing. Yeah, exactly. You're obviously still putting that pressure on yourself, not allowing yourself to be human and thinking that it's not okay to show your most honest, authentic self. And I would say certainly from our conversations today, it's okay to be authentic. You're allowed to be human. And I love that before we hit record, you were like, actually, this time in my life right now, I don't think I've ever felt better than I do right now. And it's thinking actually that, oh, the future might be really scary, but oh, my darling, what if the future's marvelous? Oh, my God, it's that. That hits the nail on the head for me.
就像，能呼吸就已经很棒了。是的，完全正确。你显然还在给自己施加压力，不允许自己做一个普通人，认为展现最真实、最坦诚的自己是不对的。我想，从我们今天的谈话来看，展现真实是可以的。你被允许做一个普通人。我喜欢你在我们开始录音之前说的话，你说：“其实，我人生中现在的这段时间，我觉得我从来没有比现在感觉更好过。”这其实是在想，哦，未来可能会非常可怕，但哦，亲爱的，如果未来是美妙的呢？哦，天哪，就是这个。这对我来说一针见血。
Oh my God, it's that. That hits the nail on the head for me. Like, why do we always assume it will be bad? What if it's great? And I was thinking about this as I was trying to go to sleep last night. You know how that works, right? When your brain's like, hello, it's time to think. But society has a big part to play in that.
哦，天哪，就是这个。这对我来说一针见血。就像，为什么我们总是假设未来会很糟糕？如果未来很棒呢？昨晚我试图入睡时就在想这个问题。你知道那是怎么回事，对吧？当你的大脑说：“你好，是时候思考了。”但社会在其中扮演了很大的角色。
So let's look at somebody like Adele. When Adele was younger and bigger and was considered not as glowed up, let's say, people loved Adele and they revered her and she's this marvelous woman. She loved herself and she was excellent at what she did, but she decided she wanted to make some changes to herself which is her absolute right as a human being. And I have seen, especially other women, berate her. Oh, she's fake now. Oh, she's, you know, she was one of the normal people and now she's not.
所以让我们看看像阿黛尔这样的人。当阿黛尔年轻、身材较胖，被认为没有那么“光鲜亮丽”时，人们爱阿黛尔，他们崇拜她，她是一位了不起的女性。她爱自己，她在自己的领域非常出色，但她决定对自己做一些改变，这是她作为一个人绝对的权利。我看到，尤其是其他女性，在指责她。哦，她现在变假了。哦，她，你知道，她曾经是普通人中的一员，现在不是了。
Really mean things. Why should a woman like Adele not be able to decide that she'd like to lose some weight and use some of the money she worked really hard to earn to glow herself up, to make herself happy in a different format? Yet, you see social media, society, newspapers, they almost belittle her for it.
非常刻薄的话。为什么像阿黛尔这样的女性不能决定她想减掉一些体重，并利用她辛苦赚来的钱来让自己变得光鲜亮丽，以另一种形式让自己快乐呢？然而，你看到社交媒体、社会、报纸，几乎都在为此贬低她。
Now, because she's Adele, she has all this support and all of this other stuff, but imagine you're just Joe and this is what's happening to you, you're trying to improve yourself, but people are just chipping away at you. And that's what happens sometimes is even society or social media or the way job specs are written that make it feel like it's not for you. Chip away at who we are and sometimes people stay still because they
现在，因为她是阿黛尔，她拥有所有的支持和所有其他东西，但想象一下，如果你只是乔，而这就是发生在你身上的事情，你试图提升自己，但人们却在不断地打击你。这就是有时会发生的事情，甚至是社会、社交媒体，或者职位描述的编写方式，让你觉得那不适合你。它们削弱了我们是谁，有时人们保持原状是因为他们
think or don't want people to think differently of me. But we talked to think before the podcast started about intent didn't we? And Adele's intent was to make herself feel better. And I think she achieved that. And I don't know the woman, but I feel really proud for her that that's what she's been able to do in her life. And it makes me sad when I see other people tearing her down. And so over the years, I've really changed who I am. Ten years ago I may
认为或者不想让别人对我有不同的看法。但在播客开始之前，我们谈到了意图，不是吗？阿黛尔的意图是让自己感觉更好。我认为她做到了。我不认识她，但我为她能做到这一点感到非常自豪。当我看到其他人诋毁她时，我感到很难过。所以这些年来，我真的改变了自己。十年前我可能
have posted something a little bit similar, partially through jealousy maybe, right? Now I'm just thrilled. Every time I see somebody do something like that I'm thrilled for them. I saw pictures of Lizzo the other day, who's obviously also been on a journey. She's being vilified because she was proud to be a curvy girl and now she's a slimmer curvy girl. Doesn't mean she wasn't proud in both spaces. So sometimes you need to check the external factors. And that's a really big thing with the imposter syndrome phenomenon, whichever we like to call it, is actually sometimes it's not. Sometimes you are being made to feel less than. And a bad culture in a workplace is a really not a bad culture, one that doesn't marry with yours necessarily. That's a version of that. And that's the thing we need to understand.
会发布一些类似的内容，可能部分出于嫉妒，对吧？现在我只是感到激动。每次看到有人做这样的事情，我都为他们感到激动。前几天我看到了莉佐的照片，她显然也经历了一段旅程。她因为曾经为自己是一个曲线美的女孩而自豪，现在她是一个更苗条的曲线美女孩，而受到了诋毁。这并不意味着她在两种状态下都不自豪。所以有时你需要检查外部因素。这在冒名顶替综合症现象中是一个非常大的问题，无论我们怎么称呼它，其实有时并不是那样。有时是你被刻意贬低了。工作场所中糟糕的文化——不是糟糕的文化，而是不一定与你的文化相匹配的文化。那是其中的一个版本。这就是我们需要理解的事情。
That is something chipping away at our confidence, chipping away at who we are. If we're having to pretend to be somebody else, it's where the misery comes from. So finding a culture that feeds you. So 18 months ago, I was diagnosed with fibromyalgia and got a blue badge. Two weeks later, my boss gave me my promotion. And I'd spent that two weeks worrying that my diagnosis would mean the promotion we'd been talking about and that I'd worked so hard for wasn't coming my way.
那是削弱我们自信、削弱我们自我的东西。如果我们不得不假装成别人，那就是痛苦的来源。所以要找到一种滋养你的文化。18个月前，我被诊断出患有纤维肌痛，并获得了一张残疾人停车证。两周后，我的老板给了我晋升。在那两周里，我一直担心我的诊断意味着我们一直在谈论的、我努力争取来的晋升不会实现了。
And what I got was promotion and a flexible fortnight where I worked nine days out of every 10 to allow for my disability because I was honest and open and vulnerable. And that was really hard for me. I'm generally quite confident. So one of my improvements that I'd like to make is sometimes I'd like to be able to be more vulnerable, hence my Facebook post. I have to push sometimes to share, but so much good came out of it when my dad died. I took a new job
但我得到的是晋升和一个灵活的双周工作制，我每10天工作9天，以适应我的残疾，因为我诚实、开放且脆弱。这对我来说真的很难。我通常相当自信。所以我想要做出的改进之一是，有时我希望能够更加脆弱，这就是我发Facebook动态的原因。我有时不得不强迫自己去分享，但在我父亲去世时，我从中得到了很多好处。我换了一份新工作
two weeks later. I think mainly because I just couldn't be bothered to speak to my boss on the phone at the time. But actually I thrived because somebody took the time to remind me in my moments of difficulty, they still believed in me. And that's what a good culture does. When you're having a good culture is great when everybody's great, but what does your culture behave like when things aren't so great for you? That's the real test when you need to dip out, when you need a moment, when you need the support you've been giving other people, how does it pay you back? And when my dad passed, my boss apologized for needing to call me but needed to offer the job and wanted it to go to me. And she was as lovely as could be about it. And actually it was
两周后。我想主要是因为当时我实在懒得和老板通电话。但实际上我蓬勃发展了，因为有人花时间提醒我，在我困难的时刻，他们仍然相信我。这就是好的文化所做的。当你拥有好的文化时，每个人都很棒，这很好，但当你的情况不太好时，你的文化表现如何？那是真正的考验，当你需要休息，当你需要片刻喘息，当你需要你一直给予他人的支持时，它如何回报你？当我父亲去世时，我的老板为不得不给我打电话而道歉，但她需要提供这份工作，并且希望我能得到它。她对此表现得非常可爱。实际上，这正是
the bit that made me go, you can't sit on the sofa being sad anymore. You can still be sad, but actually this is making it worse. So we underestimate culture sometimes until we really, really need it, Marianne, and then it really comes into its own. And I have been for the most part actually incredibly fortunate to be surrounded by beautiful human beings who have had similar experiences to me and decided sharing them with me and building me was more important than watching me suffer. And you can't put a price on that. Just can't. That made me a bit teary, but you can't price on that. Relationships should be reciprocal. It shouldn't be a one-way deposit scheme
让我觉得，你不能再坐在沙发上难过了。你仍然可以难过，但实际上这让情况变得更糟。所以我们有时会低估文化，直到我们真正需要它，玛丽安，那时它才真正发挥作用。在很大程度上，我实际上非常幸运，身边围绕着美丽的灵魂，他们有着和我相似的经历，并决定与我分享这些经历，建立我，这比看着我受苦更重要。你无法用金钱衡量这一点。真的不能。这让我有点想流泪，但你无法用金钱衡量这一点。关系应该是互惠的。它不应该是一个单向的存款计划
that you're never able to draw down on what you've put in. And if it is, that is one-sided and that is not okay. That's almost like exploitive, isn't it? It's not okay. You should be able to lean on as well as be lent on. Yeah. I mean, the concept of an emotional bank account works really well here, both from a culture perspective, but for yourself. So we think about a normal bank account, you go to work, you pay your money and your bills come out, you pay your money and your bills come out and it works in a really nice cycle. If you stopped paying your money in and your bills kept coming out, eventually most normal
让你永远无法提取你投入的东西。如果它是这样，那就是单方面的，那是不对的。那几乎就像是剥削，不是吗？那是不对的。你应该能够依靠别人，也能够被别人依靠。是的。我的意思是，情感银行账户的概念在这里非常适用，无论是从文化角度，还是对你自己而言。所以我们想想一个普通的银行账户，你去工作，你存钱，账单扣除，你存钱，账单扣除，它在一个非常好的循环中运作。如果你停止存钱，而账单继续扣除，最终大多数正常
people would be in deficit. Once you're in deficit, it's a lot harder to build that back up again. Well, we give that credence to our finances. So why do we not give that to our emotions if all you're doing is constantly paying out of your emotional bank account, or others are constantly taking from it, but you or others aren't feeding payments, you'll be in deficit. And as soon as you get into deficit,
的人都会出现赤字。一旦你出现赤字，想要再建立起来就难多了。好吧，我们对财务给予了这种信任。那么为什么我们不对我们的情绪给予这种信任呢？如果你所做的只是不断地从你的情感银行账户中支出，或者别人不断地从中提取，但你或别人没有存入，你就会出现赤字。一旦你进入赤字，
and that's kind of where I found myself a bit, right? It's really hard to bring yourself back out again. So it's really important to look at what is paying into your emotional bank account. So my kids pay into mine and then they take out my actual bank account. That's how having teenagers works, especially girl teenagers like having a broke bestie, but you need to pay in. And so many people, parents are paying in so many places a lot of the time, but actually they make the best employees if you look after them because they're used to balancing
而这正是某种程度上我发现自己的处境，对吧？想要让自己恢复过来真的很难。所以看看是什么在往你的情感银行账户里存钱非常重要。所以我的孩子们往我的账户里存钱，然后他们又从我的实际银行账户里取钱。这就是养育青少年的方式，尤其是像女孩那样的青少年，就像有一个破产的闺蜜，但你需要存钱。而且很多人，父母在很多时候都在很多地方存钱，但实际上如果你照顾好他们，他们会成为最好的员工，因为他们习惯于平衡
962 different tasks in a day. So it's that. If we try and simplify things down, you can't drink from a well that's dry, your emotional bank account, there's plenty of things you could use. But if you can sit back after listening to this podcast and do only one thing, and that is just evaluate your emotional bank account, the state that it's in, the payments that are coming out and the payments that are going in. Be clinical about it because actually taking the emotional bank account is a little bit easier. But are these balanced for me? And if they're not, what do I want to do to adjust that? So actually sometimes you find the friendship circles you're in
一天中962件不同的任务。所以就是这样。如果我们试着简化事情，你不能从一口干涸的井里喝水，你的情感银行账户，有很多东西你可以利用。但如果你在听完这个播客后能坐下来只做一件事，那就是评估你的情感银行账户，它所处的状态，正在支出的款项和正在存入的款项。客观地对待它，因为实际上提取情感银行账户里的东西稍微容易一些。但这些对我来说平衡吗？如果不是，我想做些什么来调整它？所以实际上有时你会发现你所在的友谊圈
maybe aren't quite what you needed anymore and you can silently distance or maybe actually you enjoy running but you haven't done it for months because you can't find the time. Well by finding that time would that pay into your bank account and make these other withdrawals easier? And that is what I implore people to do today, if they can find 10 minutes to just evaluate your own emotional bank account and see if it's healthy, like you would do your budget spreadsheet. Perfect. And obviously, if people are watching this on YouTube, let us know in the comments what you're making of this, which bits are resonating with you. Let us know, yeah, how your input and output
可能不再是你所需要的了，你可以默默地疏远，或者也许你喜欢跑步，但你已经几个月没跑了，因为你找不到时间。那么通过找到那个时间，这会往你的银行账户里存钱，并让其他提取变得更容易吗？这就是我今天恳求人们去做的事情，如果他们能抽出10分钟来评估一下自己的情感银行账户，看看它是否健康，就像你对待预算电子表格一样。完美。显然，如果人们在YouTube上观看这个节目，请在评论中告诉我们你们对此有何感想，哪些部分引起了你们的共鸣。让我们知道，是的，你们的投入和产出
is working for you, whether it's feeling fair. Because we are passionate about this. We believe this is really gonna serve you well in your career, in your personal life, in your family life, in your friendship circles. And we need to give ourselves permission to do these hard things. But also, like you said, we deserve to give ourselves permission to do these hard things but also like you said we deserve to be happy at work but in our relationships
对你们来说是如何运作的，是否感觉公平。因为我们对此充满热情。我们相信这真的会对你的职业生涯、个人生活、家庭生活、友谊圈产生很好的帮助。我们需要给自己许可去完成这些困难的事情。但正如你所说，我们值得给自己许可去完成这些困难的事情，但也正如你所说，我们值得在工作中、在关系中感到快乐。
in you know we get our ducks in a row and I often think sometimes not all the ducks are uniquely aligned at any one point but when they're out of line that gives you an area for growth as well doesn't it? Yeah oh, oh, it does. Sometimes my ducks are pigeons as well. Do you know what I mean? Like they're all over the place, but that's okay too. You're right. Like we get the most growth in our most uncomfortable times a lot of the time.
你知道，我们把事情理顺，我经常认为有时并不是所有的鸭子在任何时候都整齐划一，但当它们偏离轨道时，这也给了你成长的空间，不是吗？是的，哦，确实。有时我的鸭子也是鸽子。你知道我的意思吗？就像它们到处都是，但这也没关系。你是对的。就像我们在最不舒服的时候往往能获得最大的成长。
And if your ducks are a little out of alignment, that does make you feel uncomfortable. What are you gonna do to change that? I'd love to also see in the comments, people's stories of where they've done something bold and sharing their experiences of bold feelings and how that's worked out. Or if you're in the middle of feeling something, sometimes just being able to get it from here to somewhere else is the first step in that journey.
如果你的鸭子有点偏离轨道，那确实会让你感到不舒服。你会做些什么来改变它？我也很想在评论中看到人们做过大胆事情的故事，分享他们大胆感受的经历，以及结果如何。或者如果你正处于某种感受之中，有时仅仅能够把它从这里传达到别处，就是那段旅程的第一步。
And I've made it probably sound a lot easier than it was because we're talking about it in such truncated amount of time. But if you take one step today, and one step tomorrow, baby steps move mountains. It just takes time. But that's okay. That is so lovely. But they do, you know, like, sometimes we look at, Oh, I haven't done very much since a year ago. Well, why are we only evaluating a year ago? Why don sometimes we look at oh I haven't done very much since a year ago well why are we only evaluating a year ago why don't we look at ourselves 10 years ago and see how absolutely far we've come you know like when you're on a weight loss journey if you only compare it to last week
我可能把它说得比实际情况容易得多，因为我们在如此短暂的时间内讨论它。但如果你今天迈出一步，明天迈出一步，小步也能移山。这只是需要时间。但这没关系。这太可爱了。但它们确实，你知道，就像，有时我们看，哦，我从一年前到现在没做太多事。好吧，为什么我们只评估一年前？为什么我们不看看10年前的自己，看看我们走了多远，你知道，就像当你进行减肥之旅时，如果你只和上周相比
it barely looks different if you compare it to a year ago it's vast so that as well like evaluate yourself against real criteria not last week's criteria. It's not enough time because real change, emotional, physical, mental, workplace change, it's steps, it takes time. Be kind to yourself, be patient to yourself, put a little bit of pressure on yourself because as we talked about, it's healthy, but don't overpressure yourself. And find a human who you trust implicitly to be your safe space so that when you are having a moment where you don't feel like you can do it, and you will have them because normal people do, that you can go to that safe space, verbalize your feelings so you're not holding it all in and then that wonderful human comes back to you
它几乎看起来没什么不同，如果你和一年前相比，它是巨大的。所以也要那样做，用真正的标准来评估自己，而不是用上周的标准。时间不够，因为真正的改变——情感、身体、心理、工作场所的改变——是需要步骤的，需要时间。善待自己，对自己有耐心，给自己一点压力，因为正如我们所谈到的，这是健康的，但不要给自己施加过大的压力。找到一个你绝对信任的人作为你的安全空间，这样当你遇到感觉自己无法应对的时刻时——你会遇到的，因为正常人都会遇到——你可以去那个安全空间，表达你的感受，这样你就不会把一切都憋在心里，然后那个美好的人会回到你身边
and reminds you why you're doing this. They are invaluable. Yeah, and I think you are quickly becoming invaluable as well, Kelly. I've loved our chat today. And I would love if people have got ideas for future ways you'd like to hear from Kelly, let us know that in the comments as well.
并提醒你为什么要这样做。他们是无价的。是的，而且我认为你很快也会变得无价，凯利。我很喜欢我们今天的聊天。如果人们对未来想听凯利分享的方式有想法，也请在评论中告诉我们。
How can people connect with you? How can people connect with you and work with you? Are you on socials? Have you got a website? Guide us through all of that, Kelly. So I've just started all of that up. So again, I wasn't particularly proficient with website building and AI tools because I hadn't used them before. I was a sales director, so I'm very human focused. So I've just set up a website. It's under construction, but I've set it up, which is called loveseleadershipcoaching.co.uk and there's a Contact Me page on there and I'm just building up a lot of the information now, but I wanted something to be out there for people to be
人们如何与你联系？人们如何与你联系并与你合作？你在社交媒体上吗？你有网站吗？引导我们了解所有这些，凯利。所以我刚开始做所有这些。所以再说一次，我不特别精通网站建设和人工智能工具，因为我以前没用过它们。我曾是一名销售总监，所以我非常以人为本。所以我刚建立了一个网站。它还在建设中，但我已经把它建好了，叫做loveseleadershipcoaching.co.uk，上面有一个“联系我”页面，我现在正在建立很多信息，但我希望有一些东西能让人们
able to reach out. I'm going to start putting social media stuff up. So again, I would love to hear from people on what maybe they would like to hear from me. So there'll be more and more coming along, but check the website out. This podcast has been a great step for building my new brand up. And I will be looking to do some little seminars and things on things like imposter phenomenon, on building your confidence on why it's okay to want to change yourself, but still be really confident in who you are.
能够联系到我。我将开始发布社交媒体内容。所以再说一次，我很想听听人们可能想从我这里听到什么。所以会有越来越多的内容出现，但请查看网站。这个播客是建立我新品牌的一大步。我将寻求举办一些关于冒名顶替现象、建立自信、为什么想要改变自己但仍然对自己是谁充满信心是可以的等主题的小型研讨会。
So you've caught me at the very beginning of my really exciting journey. So yeah, I just, I urge people to reach out, have a bit of a read and we can go from there. And I'd love to hear from people. Lucky us to be able to get you at this stage. And you know, if you're already talking this much sense at this stage of your career. I am so excited to see where you go on this journey. So thank you for spending some of your very precious time with us today and wishing you the very best. Stay in touch. You too, Marianne. It's been beautiful to speak to you. I'll see you soon. Absolutely. Take care, Kelly.
所以你是在我非常激动人心的旅程的起点抓住了我。所以是的，我只是敦促人们联系我，读一读，我们可以从那里开始。我很想听听人们的声音。我们很幸运能在现阶段得到你。而且你知道，如果你在职业生涯的这个阶段已经说得这么有道理了。我非常兴奋地看到你在这段旅程中会走向何方。所以感谢你今天花了一些非常宝贵的时间与我们在一起，祝你一切顺利。保持联系。你也是，玛丽安。和你交谈真是太美好了。很快再见。绝对的。保重，凯利。
Bye. Oh, what an absolute treat. Thank you so much for your time, Kelly. Thank you to you for watching or for listening. When we went off camera we were like I wonder if we can find any photos of us together from the 90s and we kind of thought actually probably not because it was probably largely disposable cameras. I can't remember any photos we had taken together which is a shame but if there are any then they're on YouTube and you should be you should be too yeah like what a treat I hope you found this really helpful like we said if you do please do reach out please do let us know drop a comment if watching
再见。哦，真是太棒了。非常感谢你的时间，凯利。感谢观看或收听的你们。当我们关掉摄像机时，我们还在想，不知道能不能找到我们90年代在一起的照片，我们觉得可能没有，因为当时大多是胶卷相机。我不记得我们拍过什么合影，这很遗憾，但如果有的话，它们就在YouTube上，你也应该去看看。是的，真是太棒了，希望你觉得这真的很有帮助，就像我们说的，如果你觉得有帮助，请务必联系我们，请务必让我们知道，如果你在YouTube上观看，请留下评论
on YouTube and let us know what content you would find helpful in future to become a psychologist. Then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side. You'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Turrace. My name is Diakolo La Amujo. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate
并让我们知道未来你觉得什么内容对成为一名心理学家有帮助。那么让这成为你的指南，让这个播客陪伴在你身边。你将走上获得资格的道路。这是玛丽安·特雷斯博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我的名字是Diakolo La Amujo。我是爱尔兰的一名心理学应届毕业生。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。玛丽安博士的书《临床心理学家集体》在我的临床心理学家成长之旅中非常有帮助。玛丽安博士的书《临床心理学家集体》在我的临床心理学家成长之旅中非常有帮助。当我计划继续在英国进行研究生
studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK decline site application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and trainee clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
学习时，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我很喜欢阅读合格的临床心理学家和实习临床心理学家的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。